[Music]
the first director really gets to put
the stamp on the thing
and then the other directors have a
difficult job of
essentially singing the same song but in
different keys
each one has been completely unique
we've had three women directors on this
show and
that has been so fun i haven't worked
with so many women in my life
we're wrapping the season with claire
kilner who's just
one of the best directors she has a
really specific vision but she lets you
get there in your own freedom
we're not going to the adventure place
we're finding charlie and going home
what about dad
in episode one there's this beautiful
moment between margot and ally
where he says to margo i have this idea
to build a boat about
sure why not
look i i was thinking about a barge
upside
plenty of space downside kind of ties in
one place the end shot of season one
they're on that boat
when the guy got exactly what he planned
to do
he managed to get margo on that boat
and now she's going nowhere but with him
i think the single most important
takeaway from episode seven
is ally's face in the final shot
there's a kind of ferocity to his joy
there's also the first real indication
of a latent madness i don't know what
his end game is but i always get sort of
a sense of foreboding because i think
how far up river can you go before it
can go very dark
it's incredible the the power of family
where you see
them no matter what they get put through
they will save the kids
it's not usually like this but we made
it right that optimism
brainwashes the kids to thinking that
what they just saw is really not so bad
pretty good right mexican s'mores
they're really good then
they will never live a life that's
typical for a north american middle
class white family
but are they defined by that
americanness is that formative
psychological and cultural experience
something which can be escaped
there's no america it's just us we don't
just throw that away
season one is a travel narrative but all
travellers must
at some point reach their destination
the next journey
is about the destination and be careful
what you wish for
there's a great line by horus which is
they change the sky but not their souls
who cross the sea and if there is a
theme
to this show that's it what did i tell
you
it's perfect
[Music]
you